[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous j'ai une confiance j'ai
une confession à vous faire on est entre
nous une personne qui s'est réalisé des
choses extraordinaires
je sais faire des pâtes je choisis
rapidement mon plat au restaurant avec
des amis
pratique et je sait distinguer ma droite
de ma gauche mais malheureusement je
suis incapable de faire un simple noeud
de cravate
pourtant j'ai tout essayé j'ai regardé
des tutos en ligne j'ai lu des articles
sur l'histoire de la cravate
j'ai assisté à des conférences de
spécialistes de la cravate dans ce pas
j'ai tout essayé mais malgré ça je reste
incapable de faire un noeud cravate
pourtant comme vous devez vous dire j'ai
aujourd'hui un joli noeud de cravate
cette cravate c'est julie rer b 28
novembre 2019
9h30
j'ai tellement confiance en l'être
humain et en la bienveillance des gens
que chaque jour où j'ai eu besoin de
faire mon travail je suis allé à la
rencontre des gens et j'étais à la
recherche soit dans le métro soit dans
le rer soit dans le bus d'une julie ou
d'autres zinédine zidane de la cravate
et devinez quoi
pas un seul jour de ma vie je n'ai eu à
faire mon noeud de cravate
j'attendais des applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
je vois que parmi ceux qui n'ont pas
applaudi certains me qualifiant de
flemmard personnellement moi je préfère
dire astucieux mais dans ce cas on peut
dire que les marques ray mais pourquoi
je vous raconte cette histoire c'est
parce qu'elle symbolise ma philosophie
de vie on a toujours toujours à gagner
dans la rencontre avec l'autre et à
force d'avoir à nous aimons nos cravates
jeu j'ai été surnommé et je suis devenu
en quelque sorte comme l'a dit assia le
spécialiste des rencontres 2.0 et j'ai
donc pu décortiquer ce qui faisait une
bonne rencontre
une façon de rencontrer les gens qui
permettent d'avoir une rencontre réussie
et d'apprendre en toutes circonstances
pour apprendre dans la rencontre de
l'autre
d'abord il faut un bon état d'esprit
ensuite c'est obligatoire il faut une
confiance dans la nature humaine sans
laquelle je n'aurais jamais trouvé
quelqu'un pour me faire mon noeud de
cravate et enfin faut savoir oser oser
tout en sachant qu'il est possible de se
faire rejeter qu'on me traite de relou
dans le rer ou dans le métro
qu'on me dise pas qu'on n'ait pas le
temps que la casse h pas faire un noeud
de cravate mais mon expérience
personnelle elle le prouve dans ce cas
quand on a le bon état d'esprit ça
arrive que très rarement et maintenant
qu'on a le bon état d'esprit qu'on a les
ingrédients d'une bonne rencontre
il faut prendre du plaisir le plaisir de
la rencontre
désintéressé et dans toute recette
magique
il y à des ingrédients son secret ici
c'est la sincérité la sincérité c'est le
plus important
il ya aussi la générosité et
l'enthousiasmé et j'essayais
d'implémenter ce plaisir de la rencontre
des intéressés dans ma vie de tous les
jours ça passe par des petits gestes
vous allez me prendre pour quelqu'un de
bizarre mais quand j'étais petit je vais
distribuer aux chauffeurs de bus dans le
métro chaque fois que je déménage
geof des chocolats à mes voisins et au
quotidien j'essaye par des petits mots
comme le fait de valoriser de
compliments de complimenter les gens
donner le sourire aux gens au quotidien
et ça passe par des petites choses tu es
beau gosse aujourd'hui je suis belle
gosse aujourd'hui parenthèse refermée
mais en plus de de savoir qu'il est
indispensable de prendre ce plaisir dans
la rencontre des intéressés il y a
également une deuxième modalités de
rencontre
la rencontre qui permet de résoudre un
problème on apprend dans une rencontre
si on avoue nos problèmes si on revient
au cas de la cravate
si je mets mais têtue je ne mettais pas
montré vulnérable
j'aurais pas réveiller cette disposition
bienveillante qu'ont les gens pour
m'aider et au final tout le monde est
gagnant de julie qui se sont utiles avec
qui j'échange jusqu'aux inconnu dans le
métro qui ont les regards qui sut qui
s'illumine en voyant deux inconnus qui
s'entraident et ses lumières dans le
métro et au final caen et on se se
montre d'une l'érable ça crée une connu
une connexion instantanée entre deux
personnes et en se montrant à nu pas
trop quand même
ça permet de créer une connexion
instantanée et de cette connexion n'est
une mise en commun de deux cerveaux de
deux expériences de deux histoires de
deux vécu et en réunissant nos forces
ça permet d'avancer ensemble et ça me
rappelle cette histoire cette histoire
où cette fois où j'ai gagné ou gérant
j'ai effectué un marathon d'une
quinzaine d'heures à nancy
j'étais je vous l'avez vous pas du tout
prêt physiquement pour cette course et
en atteste mon popotin de l'époque j'ai
finalement réussi ce marathon comment
simplement lorsque j'ai effectué cette
course j'étais exténué j'étais fatigué
au bout de quelques heures et une
passante me voient elles courchevel
almeras minimum ensuite un monsieur me
ramène un sandwich et une boisson
énergisante et au bout de quelques
heures mais chaussures me brûle donc je
suis obligé de les retirer et je me
retrouve en chaussettes qui se troue et
de nouveau une personne
va me chercher des chaussettes et au
final je remporte ce marathon je gagne
accessoirement 1500 euros et plus que
l'argent j'en ressors avec une
conviction déterminée et aidé par les
autres on est inarrêtable
et ce jour là j'ai eu l'impression que
le monde entier était à mes côtés
la rencontre ça permet également de
s'enrichir on a tous et toujours à
apprendre dans la rencontre de quelqu'un
et ça peu importe de qui peu importe la
personne qu'on rencontre et ce principe
je l' ai compris de ma rencontre avec
jean charles decaux le président de jc
decaux
c'est le numéro un mondial de la du
secteur de la publicité extérieure
donc c'est toutes les affiches
publicitaires que vous voyez dans la rue
je lui ai écrit une lettre pour lui dire
mon admiration et il a accepté de me
rencontrer pendant une journée complète
et donc d'un côté on avait le dirigeant
qui influent expérimenté riche et de
l'autre l'étudiant inexpérimentés et
malheureusement pauvres et l'a priori
qu'on peut avoir sur cette rencontre
c'est de se dire les dirigeants il a
rien à apprendre de cet étudiant mais au
cours de cette de cette journée jean
charles decaux m'apprend qu'il a lu
l'une de mes lettres à ses enfants et je
le vois sous mes yeux
en pratique incorporer un de mes avis
dans ses décisions stratégiques et là je
me dis tiens je me rends compte que je
peux inspirer un des plus grands
dirigeants du monde mais je peux aussi
influencer ses décisions et c'est ça qui
est passionnant dans la rencontre
c'est que tout le monde est gagnant
c'est un échange gagnant gagnant pour
jean-charles decaux et sa mère sa mère
on s'est compris c'est mon vrai nom
alain vers de grands
[Applaudissements]
mais on peut on peut également apprendre
de la rencontre en sachant qu'on a
influencé par les gens qui nous
entourent
j'adore cette phrase qui dit que nous
sommes la moyenne des cinq personnes
qu'on fréquente le plus souvent au stade
de l'enfance
souvent on répète les gestes la façon de
penser de nos parents qui sont à ce
stade généralement les personnes qu'on
fréquente le plus et finalement ces
rencontres la familiale elles sont
imposés mais on est elle c'est tellement
vrai qu'on est le reflet des personnes
qui nous entourent que j'en suis
l'exemple vivant
moi même je suis le reflet de plusieurs
cultures la fréquentation de ma mère
italienne
ça m'a donné le côté flatteur qui est
valorise qui complimente les gens la
fréquentation mon père syrien
ça m'a donné le côté le sens de la
générosité de la solidarité et enfin la
france c'est toute ma vie c'est en plus
de l'amour de la baguette
ça m'a donné mon éducation mon caractère
et la plupart de mes rencontres dont
certaines ici dans le public qui ont
changé ma vie et ce passage de l'enfance
à l'âge adulte
ça se caractérise non plus par des
rencontres imposé comme dans le cadre
familial comme on l'évoquait mais par
des rencontres que j'ai choisi et
finalement quand quotidien on choisit
nos amis ont choisi la personne qu'on
veut être et au final tout le monde a
une qualité admirable c'est moi vous
l'avez compris c'est pas la cravate mais
ça peut être le l'entousiasme de mon
voisin c'est la rigueur dans mon
entraîneur sportif c'est l'épaule et la
bienveillance de ma meilleure amie
c'est toutes ces qualités qui quand on
se concentre sur à elle contribué à
faire de nous une meilleure personne et
cette quête qu'on a de devenir meilleur
ce soit à travers notre famille et nos
amis nos rencontres
elle nous pousse inévitablement à aller
à la rencontre des personnes qu'on
admire
nos modèles et ça a été tellement
important pour moi cette démarche que
j'ai effectivement perçu les qualités de
mon entourage de ma famille de mes amis
mais j'ai en plus c'était à la rencontre
de plus de 150 personnalités que
j'admirais le gard où l'eau est au final
une de mes rencontres
récemment qui m'a marqué c'est par
exemple celle du l'ancien patron de la
nasa charles bolden que j'ai rencontré
il ya trois semaines et je vais poser
une question il m'a répondu une phrase
qui me marquera à tout jamais il a dit
même si je cherche à être la meilleure
personne possible pour être honnête je
me considère comme une personne médiocre
l'ancien patron de la nasa
et cette phrase elle me rappelle
l'humilité lui militaire et chaque fois
que je me sentirai mon petit ego mon
arrogance
je me rappellerai de cette phrase parce
que au final plus on rencontre des gens
plus on se rend compte qu'on a à prendre
et cette phrase elle résonnera en moi
pour l'éternité
finalement les rencontres ils nous en
prennent elles font une partie de ce que
nous sommes mesdames et messieurs ce que
j'espère vous avoir transmis ce soir
c'est ce goût cette saveur de la
rencontre la rencontre c'est un espace
de tous les possibles
c'est là où la magie elle s'opère
c'est tout simplement un ami peut-être
un voisin dans cette salle un inconnu au
bout de la rue qui part un mot une
phrase une idée va peut-être changer
votre vie nous a dit en tout temps et en
toutes circonstances cet enfant ne nous
méfier des inconnus or celle ou celui
qui partagera notre vie celle ou celui
qui oeuvre à à faire de nous un homme ou
une femme meilleur or celle ou celui ci
égaiera par sa gentillesse
par sa bienveillance nos moments de
douleur a été ou sera à un moment donné
une personne inconnue
alors allons à la rencontre et ne
laissons pas l'opportunité de notre vie
filière mesdames et messieurs en cette
soirée pour moi pour ma part j'ai été
ravi de vous avoir rencontré
[Applaudissements]